sí creo que es una decepción lo que pasó
con el jumbo isma en el tour de francia
y es muy paradójico porque era el equipo
dominante era un equipo que veíamos con
el tren más poderoso de todos los
equipos incluso que líneas por primera
vez en muchos años un equipo estaba
derrotando a ese tren o estaba haciendo
superior que líneas tuvo tres victorias
en el tour de francia tenía un líder que
parecía bastante sólido que era primos
rowling que se vio muy pocas veces mal
si yo muy pocas veces mal él no dio
tantas ventajas durante todo el tour
creo que incluso las últimas las dos las
dos únicas veces que se ve que se vio
mal y que se dio fue cuando perdió
contra miguel ángel lo que son el a los
y en la penúltima etapa en donde
definitivamente se dio el tour a su
compatriota está de época char
y a pesar de ver un equipo tan
contundente si se puede decir así
durante todas las etapas de todas formas
con un equipo conservador un equipo que
no arriesgo
más allá un equipo que no lanzó a su
líder por esas ganas de protegerlos y se
puede decir así y detenerlo como en esa
cápsula de cristal rodeado de grandes
gregarios como lo estuvo no no lo dejó
arriesgar no lo dejó hacer un ataque no
fue no pensó en de pronto tener un
poquito más de diferencia para llegar a
la última etapa con un corredor que
claramente el jumbo sabía pues ya le
había ganado arroz en la en la
contrarreloj de él
el campeonato venia que sabía que podía
quitarles el título y pues finalmente
eso fue lo que pasó no no vimos un
equipo entre contundente usa una
paradoja muy rara del ciclismo que nos
dio este tour de francia' 2020 que fue
el equipo más poderoso del equipo que
siempre iba adelante el equipo que
siempre jalaba del pelotón
el equipo que nunca permitirá que otros
hicieran un trabajo diferente para poder
sacar alguna ventaja con respecto a
ellos pero que al final no pudieron pues
mantener esta ventaja que tú que tenían
sobre sobreponga chad y terminaron
perdiendo el tour de francia
de esta manera tan dolorosa